pierre guerlain en direct professeur
émérite de civilisation américaine à
l'université paris ouest nanterre et
spécialiste des états unis pierre
guerlain
bonsoir merci de répondre à nos
questions sur arte france juste avant de
voir votre image on a vu un également
des images du pupitre de joe biden qui
devrait s'exprimer à d'ici quelques
instants avec deux conférences de presse
séparées contrairement à ce qui s'était
passé en juillet 2018 quand donald trump
avait rencontré vladimir poutine alcine
qui en finlande en finlande
on a vu plusieurs plusieurs points
abordés par olivier de kerran flec sur
la conférence de presse de vladimir
poutine et notamment des points quand
même positif à savoir les ambassadeurs
qui vont réintégrer leurs ambassades des
américains à moscou et les russes à
washington avec également un travail sur
la cyber sécurité ou encore le fait
washington le site n'a pas à s'inquiéter
d'une militarisation russe de l'arctique
il ya quand même des points positifs à
retenir qu'elle analyse vous est-ce que
vous tirez de sept heures de conférence
de presse de vladimir poutine alors déjà
ce qui est positif c'est que il y eut un
sommet parce qu'effectivement tout le
monde est d'accord pour dire que les
relations entre les etats-unis la russie
était tombé au plus bas au moment on
supposait que toi tu étais trop proche
de la russie ce qui est ironique c'est
précisément lors de sa présidence que
c'est tombé au plus bas et il semble
donc qui est une ouverture des deux
côtés mais il faut quand même
s'interroger pour savoir si les forces
qui compte dans les pays en question
c'est à dire les états unis comme la
russie vont donner suite tout ce qui
était annoncé lorsque d'une part par
poutine mais ce qui va être annoncé
aussi par bayonne on sait qu'aux états
unis il ya des forces très importante
ils ont contre la reprise du dialogue il
ya peut-être des forces en russie qui
sont qui ne sont pas d'accord avec les
ouvertures
néanmoins il faut sur le long terme si
on a
lise l'histoire des relations il ya des
moments de très grande tension dans la
guerre froide
il ya des moments de détente et on a vu
depuis l'arrivée au pouvoir de poutine
en 2000
enfin 99-2000 des moments de très grande
proximité lorsque bush a reçu poutine
dans un oranje et des moments de très
grande tension
organisée autour de certains du certains
problèmes
il semblerait qu'il y ait peut-être une
possibilité d'ouverture qu'est ce que
vous attendez vous à présent de la prise
de parole de joe baydan pierre guerlain
il y en a vu lors de l'intervention de
poutine dans la conférence de presse que
même s'il y avait une volonté
d'ouverture les points d'achoppement
restent les mêmes sur les droits humains
il a botté en touche et on veut
s'attendent à ce que ben hayden
insistent pour dire j'ai évoqué ce
phénomène et qu' ils reviennent à
discours qui sera probablement plus dur
que ce qui s'est dit lorsqu'ils étaient
face à face parce que il aa
il doit faire attention à la réception
de ce sommet de ce discours aux états
unis donc je pense qu'il va insister sur
les points de désaccord qui est presque
mais aussi sur les possibilités d'accord
sur la limitation des armements
nucléaires par exemple on parle de
l'armement il ya beaucoup de points qui
a été qu'ils ont été évoquées notamment
la cyber sécurité qui était au coeur à
l'agenda de cette de cette rencontre les
deux présidents ont convenu d'ailleurs
de travailler main dans la main et
d'organiser des consultations dans
l'intérêt des deux pays oui tout à fait
la seule chose c'est que les
l'espionnage ne va jamais s'arrêter
c'est à dire que la nsa du côté
américain et les agences russes vont
continuer à centrer ce pionner on peut
espérer qu'il n'y aura pas de tentative
de déstabilisation de certaines
entreprises que ce sera un peu plus
contrôlés notamment contrôler des
criminels qui opèrent sur le territoire
de tel ou tel pays
on sait que la cybercriminalité c'est
l'une des lignes rouges
on en a beaucoup parlé pendant pendant
ce sommet mais vladimir poutine a
également évoqué je cite cette phrase
nous ne sommes pas allés dans le détail
en ce qui concerne les lignes rouges
donc du coup ils vont continuer à
travailler ensemble à dessus sur sur ce
dossier la cybercriminalité
qu'est ce qu'il faut en attendre
concrètement selon vous dans les
prochains jours les prochaines semaines
les prochains mois en matière
d'espionnage
on le dit la vérité que l'otan après et
l'espionnage continue toujours
on sait pas suite aux révélations de
snowden 2013 comment les états unis
espionné tout le monde prêt il ya eu de
l'histoire du danemark qui transférait
informations sur les leaders allemands
et français aux états unis tout ça ça va
continuer par contre il ya peut-être un
domaine où il est possible d'avoir une
coopération internationale qui implique
états unis et russie
c'est effectivement la criminalité
lorsque des individus qui ne sont pas
des agents des états attaques des
institutions et là on peut penser que
tous les états du monde ont un intérêt à
contrôler les activités criminelles que
quelle que soit l'origine de le départ
de ces attaques criminelles mais en ce
qui concerne l'espionnage évidemment
saisi cet espionnage va continuer pierre
guerlain
d'une manière générale comment est-ce
que vous analysez
cette journée jusqu'à présent même si on
le rappelle joe biden n'a toujours pas
parlé non non c'est à 19h30 qui doit
s'exprimer mais on voit tout est en
place du côté du lac léman et du centre
de presse des journalistes américains de
genève
s'il ya un bilan avant même que joe
biden ne parle lequel serait-il alors le
bilan qui est comme vous l'avez dit déjà
positif c'est les gens se parlent
il ya un retour de diplomatie ce qui
fait baisser les tensions avec les
risques d'accident du père ça c'est tout
à fait positif
ensuite pour faire le bilan en
véritables de ces vols à 2,7 de ce
sommet il faudra attendre les réactions
des systèmes politiques surtout
américains mais aussi en russie pour
voir comment c'est perçu ce obama avait
fait avait lancé un bis est un gros
démarrage des relations avec la russie
en 2011 on sait que les choses ont
dégénéré par la suite
donc il faut être très prudent il est
possible que brydon quand même faisait
partie de l'équipe obama soit moi
aiguillonnés par le complexe militaro
amérique là militaires américains pour
être dur avec la russie mais les choses
ne peuvent pas évoluer très rapidement
et là on a peut-être le début de quelque
chose après tout va dépendre de comment
les choses évoluent dans le système
politique américain pour savoir si s'est
concrétisé par quelque chose le fait que
bae d'aidé décidé par exemple de signer
l'accord taxe c'est déjà une différence
avec un du strass automne qui est en soi
positive
merci pierre guerlain pour avoir réagi
et répondu à nos questions en direct sur
sur rt france
je rappelle que vous êtes professeur
émérite de civilisation
américaine et spécialiste des états unis